Maximilian Robespierre promised you Asha,
a fairer,
more representative form of
government to the French people.
What they got instead was
a reign of terror that saw
thousands facing the horror
of the guillotine.
Among his victims were the
king and Queen of France.
When justice finally came,
it was a swift as the slice
of a blade in this week,
spire graphics.
We Wade into the terror with a biography
of Maximilian Robespierre Maximilian
Robespierre
ends of the world on May the sixth
1758 he was born and harass froms.
Historians have suspected for centuries
that is family originated from Ireland.
By the time the Max was born,
though they had been at French
citizens for many generations.
The child was conceived out of wedlock,
but by the time he was born,
his parents had gotten married
like his own father before him.
Max.
His father was a lawyer,
but not for a very successful one.
This left the family with a constant
desks hanging over their heads.
Things didn't get any easier
for the rubber SBE as when Max,
his mother died,
giving birth to a sibling when
he was only six years old.
Looking after four children was
too much for Robert sps seniors,
so his offspring were
divided among his relatives.
His mother's death had a profound
impact upon the young Max.
No longer was he the
carefree child of old.
Now.
He was Sullen and he was serious.
He also applied himself diligently to
his schooling as if he was drowning his
grief with his studies.
When he was 11 years of age,
young Robespierre was awarded
a scholarship to the least
see Louie la grounds in
Paris.
He would continue studying there for the
next 12 years emerging at age 23 with a
law degree as well as law.
He also studied literature or rhetoric
and the classics life at the prestigious
school.
It was very structured,
formerly a Jesuit institution.
There was now under the control
of the University of Paris.
The day began and ended with
formal prayers and Bible study.
The school also has an excellent library,
which Robespierre made liberal use of the
most well known incidents arising from
Robespierre is time at the school of cards
when he was 17 his excellence oratory
skills led them to being selected to
give a speech before King Louis the 16th
and Queen Marie Antoinette.
He perfected his wording and practices
delivery only to be snubbed by the role
couple who never even bothered
to get out of the carriage.
It was a personal violation and one that
he would never forget during his time
of the light.
Sear Robespierre was also exposed
to enlightenment philosophy,
especially the works of Jacques Rousseau.
Rousseau was powerful advocates for a
more democratic form of government coupled
with social empowerment's.
However,
Maximilian was not able to read
Rousseau in the library of the school.
His works were considered to be dangerous
and so copies of his famous discourse
published 20 years earlier had to
be smuggled in in his later life.
Robespierre would label his later
years of the lacy as a nursery for
republicanism.
By the time he had reached his early
twenties Robespierre was a vocal advocate
for natural rights.
He champions the rights of
the underprivileged speaking
as every opportunity.
In fact,
he was such an enthusiastic champion
of basic human rights that he became
physically exhausted to
the point of collapse.
Robespierre proved to be an
unstoppable force of nature.
This led to him becoming a familiar
as well known figure in and around his
hometown.
In the mid seventies and eighties
he joined the academy a verace.
His first speech before the academy
was part of a competition and Sean a
spotlight upon the lack
of morality and politics.
It didn't win first prize,
but he was rewarded
with a large cash prize.
This wet his appetites and over the next
few years he ended a number of essay
and poetry competitions.
He also joins and elites literary
society known as the Receiver Year Club.
Since his graduation with a degree in law,
Robespierre had established a
moderate practice from the very start.
He began taking on cases
that were controversial in
1789 he took on the state in
a case that directly challenged the notion
of lead tray to cache or imprisonment
without trial.
During the trial.
He actually wrote to the
king and personally requested
his assistance in getting
rid of this abuse.
By the seventies and eighties France
was desperately running out of money.
They had spent a lot of money and
assisting the Americans in the previous
decade.
This was compounded by a lavish amount
of spending on the part of the monarchy,
VA appointments of a
succession of finance.
Ministers do try and turn arounds.
The country's economy has little effects.
By the end of the decade,
there was a growing call for a meeting
of the estates general representing the
clergy,
the inability and the people.
Meanwhile,
the king unilaterally enacted a series
of laws to fill the royal coffers.
This included the raising of taxes and
the cutting of spending on essential
services.
The following day,
the French parliament condemns the king's
actions labeling the raising of taxes
as illegal.
The king's response where stu
simply exile the parliaments.
This,
as you might expect to lead,
do growing protests in Paris.
In response to this desperate situation,
a new finance minister was put in place.
This minister,
it was [inaudible].
He proposed a new five year plan,
which was designed to restore French
credit as well as presenting a full
accounting of the French government's
finances to whoever wanted to see it.
He called for the return of the Parisians
parliaments after their normal autumn
break.
The parliaments reconvenes November the
17th 1787 in the rare presence of the
king.
After an eight hour debates,
the parliament failed to
authorize brands five year plan.
However it King Louis the 16th went
ahead and authorize the loans that were
needed to restore credit.
Anyway,
the king left the chamber,
but the debate continued.
It was resolved that the parliament would
officially condemn the king's actions.
The following day.
The leading members of parliaments were
exiled by the king and response to this
provincial parliaments across the country
began to refuse to register laws as a
protest to the apparently does spotting
actions if the king on May the third
1788 the parliaments of Paris issued a
declaration on the fundamental laws of
the realm is included.
The rise of parliaments
who registered new laws,
the role of the estates General Lens,
the freedom of all subjects
from arbitrary arrest.
Despite this,
the leaders of the parliaments,
they were taken into custody
and lead the following day.
A few days later,
the king issued a series of judicial
reforms which were designed to to cement
his absolute power.
The reforms effectively neutralized the
parliaments of Paris in response to this
outrage prevents your parliaments around
the country refuse to uphold any of the
government's laws.
France was now operating without
any formal justice system.
The country was approaching widespread
public revolts and then attempts to
control the damage.
Finance Minister Brianne calls for a
sitting of the estates general on May the
first 1789 meanwhile,
the French government was complete the
bankrupt with no ideas to get the country
out of the red.
Brianne was forced to resign and former
finance minister Jack Neck was put back
in office and the general confidence
of the people and managed to recall the
parliaments around the country.
The Paris parliaments announced that the
estates general would meet according to
the historic precedent where the
representation of the people,
the third estate would be numerically
less than that of the clergy and the
nobility.
This was something that was met
with widespread public disapproval,
three long negotiations with the king.
Okay.
I was able to announce in December of
1788 that the representation of the third
estate would be doubled
and the estates general.
Meanwhile,
hundreds of pamphlets had been appearing
around Paris with titles such as what
is the third estate rather than
being comprised of peasants,
workers or artisans.
The third estate was made up
of lawyers and office holders,
the well to do who had enough time to
engage in the Slo process involved.
The pamphlet is strongly criticized the
power of the clergy and the nobility and
the lack of representation of the masses.
Several leaders arose among the third
estate and that included Maximilian
Robespierre.
By 1788 Robespierre was positioning
himself to play a key role in the coming
revolution.
He participated a series of
debates regarding the makeup
of the third estate and
the ratio of the three components
of the estates general.
He published a pamphlet which address
local issues and arrest with the view of
getting himself elected onto the
third estate and the pamphlets.
He strongly stressed.
Two key ideas,
the importance of elected representation
and they concern for the poor.
By now,
Robert [inaudible] has a clearly defined
notion of who the enemy was and that
was the clergy and the nobility.
In March of 1789 he was elected as a
representative from our ass to the third
estate.
He was chosen to participate in the
drafting of a list of grievances.
At the same time,
he pushed for new incentives that would
give the lower classes access to the
political system.
Robespierre is seconds.
Pamphlet was a foretaste
of things to come.
It was called the enemies
of the country on masked
the estates.
General mats on the 5th of May,
[inaudible] 1789 at first sight,
30 year old robbers spear was one of
eight representatives from a wraps and the
formal opening of proceedings.
He and his fellow third estate members
refused to now before the king.
That first day Robespierre,
he began to stand out.
He was not an imposing physical figure
and his voice was less than inspiring,
but he dressed impeccably and had an
amazing ability to recall details.
He customarily wore a powdered
wig and they formal waistcoat.
In the first week of the assembly,
he forms a breakaway group
known as the Breton Club,
which held their own meetings to discuss
the abolition of the privileges of the
clergy and the nobility.
On June the seventh Robespierre gave
a passionate speech criticizing the
excesses of the clergy.
It was one of the major motivators
for the establishment of the National
Assembly.
Three days later on [inaudible],
the third estate sent messages to the
clergy and nobility requesting that they
agree to common verification by
headcounts are receiving no response.
They declared themselves the only
legitimate representative body renaming
themselves the comments.
The public received this
news with great enthusiasm.
Eventually the clergy under much public
pressure joins the National Assembly on
the morning of June the 20th
at the National Assembly
turns up to their meeting
place.
Of a sign to find the gate's locked sins.
The entrance man's by guards.
They quickly retreated to a nearby
tennis courts on the grounds of a side.
The members were enraged at the desk.
Pot isn't of the king and shutting
out the National Assembly.
They unanimously asserted what has
become known as the tennis court oath.
They vowed to remain in session until
the constitution of the realm and public
regeneration are established and assured.
On June the 17th the king
opens the role session.
His first move was to declare
the National Assembly and valid.
He then put forward a 35
point plan for reform.
His final move was to announce this.
Nothing that the estates general did
was valid without his personal consent.
Yeah.
Once the king had dismissed the assembly,
the nobility and clerics filed out,
but the members of the National Assembly
comprising the third estate and the
clergy remained where they were.
It was declared that they would only
leave at the end of bear nets with the
entire country in support
of the National Assembly.
The king,
he backed down.
He owns it the first and second to
states to join the National Assembly.
Still the riots.
They did not end Louis send troops
to surrounds the city of Paris,
the National Assembly,
and now I've got to work and hammered
out a list of demands to be the king.
Robespierre was one of those who presented
them with the first one being that he
removed the trips,
the king.
He ignored the demands.
By the beginning of July,
there were 20,000
soldiers around the city.
Robespierre responded by
making a public statement.
No one loves the arms missionaries.
The first lesson of
nature and it's prudence,
is to repulse them as necessary.
And so it proved to be on July the 11th
the king dismissed finance minister neck
out who was still publicly popular.
This led to rage among the people.
A few days later,
rumors spread like wildfire that the
French army was a bouncer launch from
attack on the people and mobs of
citizens reacted to the impending days by
seizing at 28,000 rifles
from a veteran's hospital.
They now needed gunpowder to use them,
and as they found it,
it's an unused prison in the
city called the bass steel.
The guards tried to hold off the crowds,
but then fired into the hundreds of people
fell down debt the now out of control
and mob overpowered and killed the
guards and then gained access to the gun
powder.
When the king sent
soldiers to bring order,
they switched loyalties and
they've joined the people.
Louie now new particular trust.
No one,
not even it's protective army.
Meanwhile,
the National Assembly,
they remained in session in a desperate
attempt to restore order the king
reappointed neck out,
but the finance minister refuse to
work with the National Assembly and was
unable to stem the flow of rebellion.
I'm July the 19th he king road through
Paris and a carriage along with key
members of the national assembly
including Robert Spi APP.
Rather than crying hours
long live the king,
the people called out long live
liberty long live the nation.
Let me try to play,
keep the crowns by telling them that he
had ordered the troops to withdraw the
$150,000 citizens who flooded the streets,
took it as too little too late.
Though across the country,
armed mobs were taking to the streets
with many of them seizing control of their
city governments.
Starving people broke into grand juries
and the estates of their landlords
helping themselves to food and provisions
while other members of the National
Assembly express concern that the growing
chaos Robespierre saw insurrection as
the national expression of the People's.
Well,
it was those who opposed revolution
who are actually the real threat.
He became fanatical in his results.
He,
we doubt any and all who shaped dissent
to the apparent well of the people.
Meanwhile,
the National Assembly began
working on a new constitution,
the declaration of the rights of man
and the citizen was voted on August the
26th the king didn't respond to
the declaration in till October,
by which time the riots in the
streets were still ongoing.
He expressed concerns at a number
of the articles in the declaration.
At the same time,
he called the Alif Flanders
Regimen to society,
provide extra protection.
On the morning of October the fifth a
large group of market women marched on
velocity,
demand flour and grain.
They were met at the gates by Robert's
pm who while showing empathy for their
situation,
advised caution.
He managed to negotiate for a
single woman to meet the king lear.
We agreed to allow the release
of two stores of grain,
but again,
for Louis it was too little too late.
By evening,
a massive crowd had
gathered at Versailles.
Many of the moms,
they lingered throughout the night.
Then early on,
the morning of October the sixth a
group of them managed to break in to the
queen's bedroom.
Meridian managed to escape,
but to have her gods were killed,
but there were a couple were forced to
leave the palace and seek refuge in an
unused palace in Paris,
the Erie,
they will follow that by
a crowd of 60,000 people.
The king and queen spend the next few
months as virtual prisoners in the palace
power rested with the National
Assembly among Ridge Rubbers.
P has influence with having more
prominence over the next year.
The assembly works towards
a constitutional monarchy.
In June of 1791 the king had
had enough along with his wife.
He disguised himself as a servant
and fledge in the carriage.
He left behind the documents which
clearly denounced the national assembly.
The carriage journey got 160 miles
outside of Paris and then they were taken
back to the palace.
Yeah.
The night after the king's
attempts to flee the country,
Robespierre gave an impassioned speech
in which he stated that the deadliest
enemies of the French when the Austrians,
he threatened war but counter
revolutionary forces within France itself.
He also said that the king should be
counted as one of those enemies of the
nation.
This speech,
it broke the assembly
into on the one side,
there were those who clung to the
idea of a constitutional monarchy.
Well,
those who sided with Robespierre,
we're in favor of republicanism.
Robespierre.
He began to call for the public
trial of the king on July.
The 17th or group of petitioners who
supported the call were confronted by the
national guardsmen and the melee
that followed 50 of them were killed.
The French constitution was completed
in September of 1791 effectively putting
an end to the work of the assembly.
Robespierre resent to harass where he
was welcomed as a hero of the people.
Meanwhile,
the king had declared war on Austria.
Robespierre spoke out against the war
stating that it was not in the interests
of the people and he feared that it
would galvanize them around the king and
thus destroy the revolution.
During the spring of 1792 there were
vocal calls for the creation of a French
republic.
Robespierre,
however,
had changed his tune and was now in
favor of a constitutional monarchy.
However,
when a large protest
outside between early on,
the third anniversary of the tennis court,
oath turns nasty.
He found himself in a standoff
with the kings key enforcer,
General Lafayette,
who stood ready to put down the marches
with force protests at the tweeter.
He continued culminating in the king
and queen being forced to flee and seek
protection from the National Assembly.
More than a thousand people were killed
that night and it's way the monarchy was
officially dissolved in the royal family
were taken into custody as prisoners of
the state.
Following these events,
Robert's be app was elected
to the insurrection commune,
which was the governing body
which now kept order in Paris.
He oversaw a period of interrogation of
royalists for a raft of suspected crimes
against the state.
Many of these royalists prisoners were
pulled from their prison cells by mobs
and simply massacred.
This is where I'm simply handed to
eventual mob is after mock trials in the
first week of September,
1970 to around 1,400 people
were killed by these mobs.
Robespierre insisted the commune also
investigate counter revolutionary
activities so it would condemned
28 people to death by the heading.
In the midst of this carnage,
elections were held for a
new constitutional assembly.
Rubber spear was elected
as a first deputy.
Still there where those within the
assemblies that's rejected to his violent
methods of enforcements through force
or arguments here sidelines than winning
the day with his conviction that
the ends justified the means,
no matter how violent the means
may be the trial of the king.
I'll have again on December the
26th 1792 three weeks later,
he was found unanimously guilty.
Robespierre himself sums
up the will of the Times.
It is where the regrets that
I must pronounce the fatal
truth that King must die
so that the country may live.
France executed it's king.
On January the 21st 1793 Robespierre
he did not attend to the occasion.
On July the 20th 1793 Robespierre was
elected to the committee of public safety,
which had been established
just a few months earlier.
The committee began to take action
against federalist revolutionists.
Mass executions were ordered in Leo,
which was a hotbed of royalists sympathy.
Revolts were breaking out all over
leading the convention to declare terror.
The order of the day on September
the 17th they pass laws,
allowing them to put to death.
Anyone who was implicated as a supporter
of tyranny caught up in the net of the
reign of terror was Marie Antoinette's.
After a sham trial,
she was sent to the guillotine on
October the 16th 1793 Robespierre.
He now set his sights on his
former National Assembly,
opposes the girder nests.
They were do you need tried and found
guilty and sent to the Guillotine?
Controlling all of these
executions was rubbers Pierre,
who famously declared to punish the
oppressors of humanity is clemency to
forgive them is barbarity.
Those who were opposed Robespierre in
the assembly found themselves facing the
guillotine.
Before long he had absolute
power within the committee.
He had become a virtual dictator literally
with the power of life and death in
his hands along with his immense power.
Robespierre grew increasingly paranoid.
Then there was an attempt on his life in
May of 1793 the following month he was
elected president of the convention.
He immediately enacted changes to allow
him to condemn even more people to
death.
[inaudible] were reduced to
mere condemnations and all
accused were denied legal
representation.
He even created a new category of
criminal gold enemy of the people.
This blanket term could cover
anything from serving sour wine.
Do sending a letter to England.
Yeah,
it's the punishments.
It was always the same
death by guillotine.
By this time,
Robespierre had gone too far.
The people were beginning to
reject his despotic rule of terror.
His political enemies orchestrator,
they falsified lesser,
which appeared to implicate Robespierre
and an attempted coup to Tom.
He defended himself against charges
of dictatorship in a two hour speech.
In this speech,
she warned of a conspiracy that was
being hatched against the republic,
but it was all to no avail.
The next day he was arrested
or needs to be freed.
Shortly thereafter,
like trips from the Paris commune,
Robert's Vn and his defenders found
themselves hold up at the Hotel de Ville.
They were declared
outlaws by the convention,
which means that when course they could
be put to death immediately when the
convention forces closed
in on the hotel rather SBM,
and as those who were with him
all tried to commit suicide,
some of them succeeded,
but Robespierre has attempts to blow out.
His brain's only managed to shatter his
lower jaw with blondes pouring from his
face.
Robespierre was laid on the table in the
room of the committee for public safety
before being transferred to
the cell that is housed Maria,
and it's going to ask prior
to her date with a guillotine,
the end game for Robespierre on July
the 28th 1794 when he became the final
victim of his reign of terror,
seconds before the blade fell,
the executioner ripped off the
bandage that keeping his jaw together,
causing him to let out
an all mighty scream.
It was soon silenced by the deadly blade.
Finally ending the carnage that
Robespierre has warped view of justice had
wrought.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.